hello my name is Sergei naumov I'm from
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
and in this talk I'm going to present
the tool set that we have developed
together with a
rahuri Oliver professor at Texas A&M
University and this tool self helps to
understand how structure of the complex
our nonlinear systems determines the
behavior that we observe thank
hello everybody my name is Sergei Toma
and today I'm going to present a joint
project with Rogelio liebe from Texas
A&M about structural dominance analysis
of dynamic systems and to give you a
little bit of a background where this
project is coming from let me give you
some primer on system dynamics which is
a computer simulation approach to the
analysis of complex social economic
environmental and other you know human
systems and has roots in control theory
which was a and it was developed by
Professor Jay Forrester at MIT in the
late fifties who actually was a already
very prominent engineer at that time and
then did a lot of work in server
mechanisms and he realized that actually
principles of feedback control that
Houston engineering they could as well
be used and very successfully used in
management of large scale real-world
systems so so this framework is approach
that we use that that's basically based
on feedback thinking and the feedback
thinking we understand that basically
the behavior of a system the behavior
they observe it's a result combination
of different endogenous conserves like
interactions that occur between elements
in that system
and where under feedbacks we understand
like this loops that start in at some
point in the system and then they
propagate through the system after a
certain pathway and return back to the
original point and as a result they
potentially change the states of the
system and influence in your futures so
therefore we actually are focusing
purely on the understanding why the
system works the way it works and just
to give you a little bit of the very
simple example this is a classical bass
model of diffusion market diffusion of
products or services that has very
simple structure just two state
variables or stocks we call them and
this is they depicted as boxes and this
is a stylized pipe between represents
the rate of change of those levels and
all the other variables around it so
exhilarated to create the pathways those
loops to understand how the variables
are connected at what influences what so
this model if you run that generates
classic s-shaped logistic curve that you
know you see on the right hand side and
this is where basically you have the
exponential growth in the beginning and
then you have leveling off and the
slowing down the dynamic so it's clear
there is something going on and
and how you wanna understand how the
system works so the traditional methods
that we use they're largely a trial and
error simulations and experiments and
ctvt analysis and scenario analysis of
different sorts where you're basically
trying to discover the structures by
changing parameter values and different
combinations of them in trying to switch
in no loops on and off in trying to see
which is influential way and so in this
case the model is simple so you can
really clearly understand that in the
beginning there is a exponential
positive loop reinforcing loop that
word-of-mouth loop where the more people
you know become adopters of the product
they more so effect stronger is the
dynamic of converting other potential
adopters and endemic in the middle their
dominance shifts in other words you know
that the other loop becomes much more
prominent and this is the negative for
balancing loop which is basically
exhaustion loop so you just run out of
people and then you convert everybody
it's a very simple model so you can
actually do that by hand and through
different simulations so the problem is
that if you have a large scale model the
analysis of large models is much more
difficult because models are largely you
know nonlinear by the nature and there
is a complex nonlinearities and it has a
numerous feedback loops that interact at
the same time at different time delays
and dozens of state variables in many
many soft variables and other soft
variables to understand the variables
that are hard to measure you can't
really measure you know fatigue or you
can't really measure morale you know
there are some approximations so there
are different dependencies there
uncertainty in links between variables
that are soft in their nature so in this
circumstances traditional methods they
become an art right you can always you
know miss something when you analyze
this model or you can decide and not to
cover all parameters because just two
computational intensive or you just miss
something and then even for simple
models then you know what you actually
decide is the sort of like a course of
the observed behavior you can falsely
attribute that to this certain making
feedback mechanisms you can decide well
it's because of this looks here and
there and maybe so the parameters for me
to change would be X and y and however
it might be in fact as a result of a
completely different set of feedbacks
that is driving this outcome right so
it's a it's basically a now becomes
clear it's difficult to understand what
causes the observed behavior without
understanding dominance patterns relying
to underlying structure of the model
right so then we need an exhaustive
analysis and something more robust and
replicable than just you know that art
that I've just talked about so it's it's
very actually nice to think about from
the mathematical perspective so the
system of that sort can be described as
a set of uncoupled you know first-order
ordinary differential equations and we
call so called in the state equations
where the rate of change of every state
variable in the system is a function of
the other state variables and some you
know exogenous or input variables
so given this model structure giving
these functional dependencies and the
initial conditions and also the
trajectories of all the input variable
so the behavior of the system is
completely determined so this is great
however the parabola is in general form
there is no analytical solution to a
nonlinear system so even with few state
variables few levels they can generate
very complex behavior including even
chaos behavior so what we can do about
this so so one of the approaches that
can be useful here is actually try to
linearize this system around the
operating point and if you do that using
Taylor expansion so you can actually
come to this sort of like a functional
form where the rate of change is a proxy
approximately its linear combination of
the other state variables in the input
variables so for such linear system
there is a solution and there's very
well established in the linear control
theory so and then the function
basically the the solution becomes a
function of the structure defined by
these matrices a and B which are
matrices of the partial derivatives so
the key element now in this solution
becomes the eigen value so eigenvalues
of that matrix a and so then the
solution for for the all the other state
variables in the system becomes just a
purely function of the exponents of this
eigen values where the weights depend on
the nature of the eigen value so the
eigen values are complex that would be a
sine function that represents
oscillation otherwise that just will be
the exponential trajectories so and just
to illustrate how it works so let me
just show you a very simple system so on
the left hand side you have the
representation and the differential
equations and this in the middle this is
the representation of the so if like a
structure of that system you have to
where state variables x1 and x2 and two
rates of change and one parameter p1 so
if you run that with the parameter P one
being equal to
one then you have these trajectories on
the right and both stocks they erode
over time so and now if we use the
system matrix that matrix a that's
basically written here and if we try to
compute that so we can get the
eigenvalues here in symbolic form as a
function of this parameter P and then
assuming that say P is equal to 1 like I
said we have this list of tigon values
and this is a real eigenvalue so we know
that now in the system there are two
behavior modes that are exponential so
there is no oscillation in the system
and we can even plot this behavior modes
and get something like that right so
then basically all the trajectories to
fold two stocks that we see will be the
function of combination of this behavior
mode so now the the question is now you
want to understand now okay so every
trajectory of every state variable in
the system is completely determined by
this behavior modes now you want to
understand what influences these
behavior modes because if you want if
you can do that then you can actually
understand now how can you control that
right how you can control it properly so
this is not a very new idea so it has
been around since 80s and then buttocks
actually didn't get too much traction
because of the intentional computational
intensity and the cause of the fact that
there wasn't just no simple serve like a
unified solution how you basically can
combine all the pieces of the system so
you have to get the model right first
and then you have to sort of like
simulate it somewhere and they have to
get the data out of that model and then
you have to import that in some other
software package where you basically do
the analysis and then you export that
somewhere else so it wasn't really a
very streamlined and clear sort of like
a solution so what we're going to show
you today is that the word that's based
in the what we call structural dominance
analysis framework where we have two
different pathways or two different
parts so one part is the what we call
loop eigenvalue elasticity analysis
which is what I just showed you it's how
you under ten tafoya's behavior modes in
the system and then once you did then
how you link the loops the feedback
loops in the system to the actual
observed behavior modes so the challenge
here a little bit is that you want to
understand
individual influences of which
individual loop on the eigenvalues or on
the behavior modes however so there
sometimes could be overlap in the loops
you know some links in the loop they
might participate in multiple loops so
if you want to change let's say I'll
gain in one loop or gain basically rate
of change that loops this propagates
around the loop and that might not
necessarily be affecting only one loop
it might also affect the other loops you
know and then so then the results will
not be actually clear so there is a
solution that comes from the control
from the graph theory where we can
actually identify independent loop set
and such that you know basically you can
independently change the gain of the
sloops so the problem a little bit of
here is that the independent loop set is
not unique right so there are multiple
options how you can get that that so
approach that we use it the shortest
independent loop set were basically we
use the loops that are shortest in in
size so that'll have the least number of
parameters so that's one part so once
you understand which loops affect you
know the behavior most now you want to
understand how this behavior modes
basically project on the state variables
because now you want to understand what
effect it has on the trajectories of the
variables that you care about and this
is the second part we call dynamic
decomposition weight analysis which is
now using eigen vectors of the same
matrix a and then gives you the
projection of those eigen values of
behavior modes I'm sorry now on the on
the stocks alright so what we have now
is the complete tool set fully done in
Mathematica in a notebook that has very
streamlined workflow so you have you
have the model you upload it and
Mathematica and then you do the analysis
you generate a report and it's a single
package so it doesn't require you know a
bunch of different stuff so the sort of
like all sorts of different parsing in a
you know conversion of these functions
from the modeling environment to
mathematically is done sort of like here
behind the scenes so that user doesn't
see that and it becomes very very
elegant search like an environment for
people to explore models now right so
then let me just show you how it looks
and so this is the best board that you
get and then so let's just you know try
to analyze this example model that we
have here so we have this information
about the
structural you know composition of this
model we can run this model or simulate
that we have this trajectories for both
variables that we observed on the graph
before and now we can do this you know
analysis like I said the configuring out
what the behavior modes are so this is
the system that the graph that shows you
there in the system there are two
eigenvalues two behavior modes and
they're real and they constant over time
so the system is very simple than that
there is nothing fancy about that we
could easily understand that you know
doing analysis by hand but this is using
this is working for all sorts of complex
systems where these interactions would
be much much more complicated and now we
can do the projections like I said of
the behavior modes and if you look at
that because this is actually a linear
system that linearization that we are
doing so we have to choose at what point
we're doing linearization because again
if this is a nonlinear system then of
course the trajectory will change and
linear system one would be good for
around the operating point but because
this system is linear so they actually
the results that we get the
decomposition we get is exactly equal to
if you compare these two graphs coming
from simulation and from the
decomposition that we get so then the
equation is clearly you know specifying
here all these components just you know
this behavior modes and then the the
weights so you get exactly this
trajectory and so once you have that you
confirm that visually so you have this
you know the behavior that you
understand and you like so then you can
go to elasticity's and then you can
understand that for example you have
only one parameter in this you know
model p1 we had we saw and so this is
the influence of this parameter on the
weight and on the behavior mode itself
so we know that we if we increase the
this magnitude of this parameter now so
our system will actually behave more
aggressively so it will erode quicker
you know there will be a stronger
projection of the eigenvalue and then
not because eigenvalues erosion so it
will be a stronger erosion plus the
eigenvalue itself the behavior modes
will be stronger so this is in a
nutshell again this is very simplistic
model but you can run much more
complicated models here and get the same
level of analysis relatively quickly so
just for the sake of completeness here
so that some few on the interface
related takeaways that we have from from
this process of converting the
you know basically different tools into
one tool set and and also improving some
algorithms so but the interface is the
important part here so you want to have
a clear
you know flow control and this is very
simple and trivial it might be on the
surface but in the end what you're going
to do you're going to be you can even be
guiding a user through the interface in
such a way that there is no opportunity
for people to make sort of like a stupid
mistake or you know generate some
exception in the in the in the routine
so for example you have this you know
load and run button even you you should
prevent you know run from being useful
until you know load is complete and now
we have this load and then the run is
running right so this is one part where
basically you want to clearly delineate
the the boundaries of what user can do
at each point in time so and then that's
pretty much self-explanatory but can
easily you know sleep through cracks of
this modeling process so this is
important so the other part is message
capturing especially if you're dealing
with something that you're not
controlling fully like you want a user
to upload any model so it means that you
know mathematical functions can generate
all sorts of you know response to this
you know input if the input is crappy
right so you want what you want to do if
you don't want to ruin this nice
dashboard that you have and so that
basically if the exceptions occurred and
they will be you know listed underneath
the interface so you don't want to do
that so you're capturing this message
what it actually does it uses this sum
and basically undocumented very useful
sort of like a function which has been
in an inherited blog which you know it
comes like it carries over the
definitions for the function that you're
passing through and then you modify that
and what I'm doing here is basically I'm
capturing all the capturing all the
information about the errors that were
on messages that were generated through
the during the execution of the function
and I'm passing it back to the parameter
of this function so let's say if we have
this message as the MC list we can put
it as a dynamic variable here and let's
say if we just simply say 1 over 0 it
will generate this error infinite
expression and put on directly in the
notebook so we don't want to have that
if instead we use our function that
captures messages so see we evaluate
that nothing happens here in interface
but I capture that message and they can
show it in
in my elements of my interface where I
wanted to be in the windows or something
so then another one so it actually keeps
populating right so I can do it as long
as I want so this is something very very
useful we found
okay so then future improvements and
directions so we you know there are some
different things that we want to you
know it do for the model part including
you know parsing different you know
exotic functions and then some you know
trigonometric functions in Mathematica
they are camelcase
so which is not case for the modeling
environment usually so we want to you
know deal with that so the we want to
you know also work with a little bit
more complex input parameters and
variables for the system because right
now we are mostly focusing on the
endogenous behaviors so conic
abstracting away from some disturbances
that might be introduced through the
inputs but the big thing we want to
actually move forward here is actually
trying to use machine learning control
for parameter as and then some policy
design as for example using you know
this adaptive feed forward control in
order to be able to analyze more
complicated models and get get more
insightful results so and another big
part for us is actually moving from the
notebook based interface so this is a
single package so you can actually do
that if you have a mathematical license
but even if you do have mathematical
license but you know frequent user it
might be a little bit intimidating for
people to start doing that just for that
single task so we want to move to the
web-based interface and this is just
right now a big dynamic object so it's
not really very much hundred percent
I immediately portable to the cloud so
you have to do certain things about it
so you either have to modify the
interface and put it in the cloud
notebook or you have to actually
generate a bunch of API functions and
then use the HTML and then java scripts
to interact with that in a display so
it's not really clear for us so which
way it should go
and then we were you know been talking
to different people so if you have any
ideas and suggestions how to do that we
would be very great will be a very
thankful and that's it for today so if
you have any questions we'd be happy to
answer and thank you
you